are we about to play the one with all
the infected fog no okay so i'll save my
fog boosters this is c1 ah we don't need
any boosters for c1 we we died in the
room with a bajillion uh tentacle men oh
you know what i'm remembering that i
need to run sniper don't die because i
was our sniper i mean you know is knife
knife better
knife is it's yeah good to have some
knives i think two knife two spear might
be pretty good actually but if you want
a knife
the thing about the knife is it's very
fast um it can't kill like tentacle
people but it's quick to charge and you
can run with it yeah you can run charge
which is amazing yeah you can stab three
in a row pretty much like bam bam bam
that sounds way better than spear spears
if you don't hit the head there's a huge
damage penalty yeah so you basically
don't kill anything even little ones
unless you hit headshots yeah exactly so
it's like a skill trade-off and the
range is super short what we're saying
is we're really good at this game and
can handle this you need the the babies
yeah
little baby needs a big long spiel
yeah i do i also learned about the
damage zones on enemies like obviously
head does damage but back does just as
much damage as a front head shot and the
back of the head does twice as much
damage because it counts as a head shot
and back at the same time so back real
life yeah exactly oh i know i'm not
ready now i did wait my my booster or my
master go
did you press drop instead of prepare
maybe you throw it away if you drop it
it's not prepare and then drop oh
it's prepare and leave it i thought too
prepare and then drop it don't do
anything yeah exactly it was no well i
just put one into the ether this would
never happen to the people
if you can just drop them in i gotta
like shove a little bit yeah
have you not been stunning your butthole
enough well i thought after uh dr
tarshish way back in the day that my
butthole would be adequately prepared
for anything but i guess shrinkage
happens over the years
doctor
what what is that a reference to oh and
i had tailbone surgery but everyone
thought it was a colorectal uh thing so
they just kept putting their fingers in
my butt
was that did we talk about that a lot
that i'm just not remembering or well
i've talked about it a lot maybe not
with you guys i had to have three
tailbone surgeries in college after i
like fractured part of my tailbone but
this new information i met with
each one of his fingers was the size of
two of mine together he had the biggest
fingers of anyone i've ever seen in my
life and those puppies were deep inside
of me
and like i you know it happened i went
to several doctors who had to probe
around but him i clinched onto the side
of that bed and there were tears pouring
down my face it hurt wow man there was
not room inside of me for that man's
hands but he made room
with that attitude
he made room for the reason he was known
as the fart fixer
[Laughter]
oh i thought i thought it silenced him i
thought he
no now it sounds more like air passing
through a leather foggy person
now every time you fart you're just like
like a breezy window you're here in a
room with a bunch of people who don't
know you and just like
someone's like what the f what was that
what's a good thought what's the good
iceberg baby yeah like ah nah
there are dudes over here fyi get em
knife boy you got it
knife coming up
watch this nonsense this is what the
next night better than spirits i miss
that
witness
all right there you go
whoa there was one more
he's not dead he's not dead
[Laughter]
yeah
it's exactly what i said would happen
you
[ __ ] it up
no
i got two of those guys good we got any
we got any life refills yet i'm already
kind of hurting did you get hit after
one room
because two of them charged down the
stairs while mark was showing us the
power of the knife well bathroom i don't
know
i killed you
as best did i miss something you
literally missed a very long
conversation about how podcast i'm sorry
i don't have to tune you guys out it
just happens yeah yeah yeah room clear
this about to be no this ain't fog level
no no this is not fog level thankfully
no one in here no no one in here room
clear
a medpack
we did not explore these other rooms
last time should we explore them or just
plow ahead to where we need to go i mean
we're going to go that way anyway so
either we have learned about this game
it's guns out sprint forward boys
did we ever figure out if higher or
lower is better i think higher is worse
higher higher what i think i think a
larger
class four
highers i think higher classes
it syncs up to the number of circles you
have to do so class four means four
individual batches of circles yeah wow
that's not very good at all we got one
of these guys came from like oh nice boy
i mean you can yeah i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go close this that's true upstairs
door i guess
uh sean seems like the you're clear in
this room on the other room
next there's a bunch okie dokie i don't
think we need to clear any further than
this side room because this would be the
only one that comes in
so if we plonk this up
[ __ ] this side room all right
i hate this side room
i mean my homies apparently do right now
hate this side room
not repaid it click to find out why nine
out of ten dentists hate this side room
you see those tick tocks where people
are like the lawyers giving you advice
and like they don't know that i know
this and then they just talk back to
management and like settle for more yeah
i like laughing at lawyers on tick tock
but there are a couple i who are like
they're actual lawyers there's one who's
my favorite his whole thing is every
people will put questions and scenarios
and his only response ever is like [ __ ]
the police shut your [ __ ] mouth if
they ask you a question you don't say
[ __ ] they they tell you they're
arresting you you say yes sir and you
get arrested and you sue their dumb
asses later you shut your [ __ ] mouth
and like yeah
that's kind of good advice
yeah
there's a big flashlight up in that box
whoever wants
power of the sun
no it's mine
you you big sun boy that's okay
i want to be the degenerate you didn't
have to tell him that mark sometimes we
need to see things and sometimes we need
to never see him again
it's very similar
i guess
we're good oh they to the right yeah
that doesn't sound like left okay here
we go
chase inform that i get the far one
oh yeah they're banging on the door
yeah good seafoam good good job
i think i'm gonna i'm gonna put this
thusly
hope that that's a good thing to do
all right whoa whoa where from where
whoa work on us
[Music]
stop being alive
ow
damn shooty boys can we get pings mark
can we get penguins oh yeah i forgot
that's part of my job
hang on to the left we got these two
right here
right near the green oh
i got these far ones whatever the hell
green boy is
oh guess
there's a lot of them oh yeah a lot of
them coming in
over here i'm repositioning my turret to
cover that side watch out watch out okay
watching out oh where'd you come from
buddy
reload please
oh get him yeah
we got these dudes
show your backheads to me how did that
would hit me i dodged like a god
okay dude the knife is way better than
the spear i'm not using this anymore
dude knife is way better than the spirit
yeah especially the entire
yeah
spear boys for life right other spear
boys could have been a knife gang yeah
oh
wait no
uh no we're good there's probably some
enemies over the left oh yeah what is
that i seek pain
hello there's a couple here
don't waste your ammo wait
that's what my mom said tonight but i've
only got a shitty spear i have to
i don't have any chances
it's not yours
all right there's nine in the room
beyond they're pretty tightly grouped oh
that sounds like knife territory it's
nice
hang back a minute
where are they where are they uh there's
two over here to my left two let them
snow oh yes there are you're right about
that is there one in their corner
there's yeah it's it's a group of four
back there actually it's not just two
more
oh there's a bunch of them yeah four
yeah
far left
yeah two in the far back i think
this is bad what if i use the power of
the sun uh don't
oh there's nothing oh
yeah hey
can you guys all stop okay
oh god who did what oh god oh god
i didn't even move
uh
oh yeah can the knife open up locks
oh look how low our health is hey yeah
come here
i have health i just got healed i've got
a one use what do you got a five let me
let me get rid of this on you as long as
you're below 80 it's worth using a
medpack because i think it's 20 a pop
yeah but you know what if one of you
like goes down and needs it even more
after that no knife boys never go down
your spiros need the help the spirits
oh you you spiro agnews really needs the
med bag
spears are the wave of the future they
look artificial don't don't try wait we
know that we're inferior
no
i'm in denial and i'm gonna die on this
hill
you will yeah
you will i'm gonna die very painfully on
this hill i'll die of touching your
useless shaft
that's not the first time i've heard
that uh find the data cube in zone 147 i
guess i don't need the terminal then
this is the thing that's error yeah this
is the thing where we had to run
straight so we activated
running
um i did this and i figured that it's
it's a good idea to put a sentry right
here shooting towards the door because
things spawn from behind here and you
can kind of slow them down the ones that
chase yes
remember okay go ahead nope i'll drop
mine you drop i'll drop mine we'll leave
mine mine is good yeah yeah okay we're
going where should we drop the second
one keep it in case of terrible terrible
[ __ ] happening
of course there will be
there will be oh my spears like in
everyone's way i feel like i'm
inconvenienced
[Music]
yeah
do be aware that uh
things are sleeping here so
it's only when things come from behind
so we should be able to take out some of
these dudes
oh god you're right it is
that's that sentry gun at work
what is happening what is happening holy
[ __ ] i just got absolutely wrecked oh
yeah they came from behind the sentry
gun did not take care of those i'm down
i'm going down boys
see i bet you i wish i had my med kit
now huh yep okay we need to [ __ ] we
need to go yeah we gotta go
we'll come back for these boxes later
except for this one lock melt i'm going
to lock it melted
i'm going down again
where are you where are you i'm right
next to whoever was by the box oh i'm on
the floor shoots like a lot of stuff
yeah there's something that shoots like
an eight round hurry and it's all
very
yeah just keep moving just move just
move
i'll shock them when they come around
this door but those guys i think are
going to keep spawning you there mark if
you want yeah drop another sentry
pointing back okay one of them is dead
yeah right there right there right there
yeah those are mines you know what i'm
gonna put the mine down frick it there
is a key somewhere here we do need
in one of these boxes there's a key
yeah there's a locker back there i
didn't check
[Music]
eventually if we find another computer
terminal we should be able to query it
but i don't know where one is
i think there's one in one of the air in
the area where it is i think there is
oh boy
stand still yeah stand still for just a
sec would you there we go
55 good good yeah let's move up now we
can go straight to the end oh i gotta
hack this door
or i can melt it with my lock melt
oh that works on those oh yeah it does
i thought it was only for actual locks
all right shoot first then i guess
yeah we're running anyway what's the
point of wasting time
you're right
i'm sorry i shot you in the butthole ow
my butthole see
that one was not dead
who the hell
[ __ ] there is a box over here on the
floor i'm gonna try and get real quick
all right because i've got so much extra
health yeah
these guys are weak never mind i'm just
gonna knife them
no i can't do that you have a spear it's
still usable ah it's not knifing them
it's not the same okay doors open
outside behind you right behind you okay
get in the circle guys right here
circle circle circle
coming from behind me get out no you're
good there's nothing there no typical
spear guy in the back wow you go down
twice and you get here last
listen i was doing stuff it's almost
like it's almost like that makes sense
what i just said
[Music]
kind of let me prove myself wrong
all right i think this is the one right
this is the console somewhere in here oh
yeah someone needs to do it i'll do the
typing types
all right
yeah
mark uh commands oh god uh deactivate
alarms
that sounds like a good idea
activate gotta spell it right deactivate
alarms son of a [ __ ]
deactivate
you guys
all right the alarms are off how do we
go we got one more wave oh boy yeah we
did get him get him
[Music]
oh it's a big one what am i doing
holy crap
got him going up trying to knife him
yeah that's the way we like it
the true power
any issue whatsoever yeah that was
pretty well i suppose we should
recollect our turrets
is it better to use it on you now with
the tool refill does it work
no yeah you can't if we don't have our
turrets in hand yeah
so mark you were saying we should leave
them though yeah they'll come into your
possession when we go to the next as we
warp to that desert area they want to go
they automatically go to your inventory
this is our objective in the next room
and then we backtrack oh this this
security sequence is fine and takes
forever it's all good at least we all
have lots of health for this
um
we have almost uh 120 health between all
four of us
that's all that's a big number almost
one person listen good job you always
recover to 20. so we're good wait here's
one right here hey look
excuse me wade let me
no no allow me oh wow i got it i got it
first allow me to melt
uh there's nothing in here
i got a data cube
ah hey look my turret's back
my turret still has full ammo i guess it
didn't shoot anything
are you sure the bursts are better
get ready
here they come
hold the line
what line
i was running around
i'm gonna run in front of you now please
do not shoot everybody's wanting the
spawning like i can't ping that my nose
over there can't hit these things you go
your spears are the only thing oh oh i
shouldn't have reloaded there's one
right now
thank you but you had my back
i was reloading we're good over here
never mind
i am missing all my shots
kill some of these [ __ ] until we
survive it's a it's a time thing you
don't actually even need to kill them
but they do kind of get old they're
gonna take their precious health away
i was ready for that
all right
there's an ammo pack sitting somewhere
i'm just pinging it right now
it's somewhere over there it's like to
your right i think to my right
i can get it here wait what it was like
down this way i thought i saw a ping
like down over here oh here it is
got it
cute mark needs a hey yeah hey hit me
with one of those hey
stop what are you gonna do about it
red light
green knight
wait spedici stop moving
you can never sing the song if you want
me to play the game
there you go see i got him to stop for
you wade thank you oh yeah yeah three
gonna make the sounder i can't go okay
what was this um
are you mocking
the korean language right now
[Music]
wait guys i learned a thing and it's
cannot really pertain to this but like
it reminded me of it there was an
apparently an italian pop singer in the
1970s who was really jealous that
american music was doing really well in
italy and so to prove a point he wrote
an american rock song i don't know if he
didn't speak english if i did it on
purpose but the lyrics were nonsense
words that just kind of sounded like
englishy vowel sounds oh yeah
and it was on the top of the charts and
he was like see you're idiots is it
called pearl jam oh my god first you
sold the korean nation and now you can
serve and sold all of seattle what the
bread letter or whatever the hell that
song was called
the bread letter
they had many amazing songs from the
albums
doesn't mean it's right are you mocking
your english language right now
how dare you
guys i got lost hey i'm way behind you
guys i got lost hang on i'm just looking
for other boxes in these other rooms
yeah i go at galobies don't worry bro oh
we gotta come on the door issue over
here should we break the comb or should
we there's another door down here oh
never mind we're gonna go around it
leave your come smash around i've seen
this problem before the old comm door
situation
we've all raised teenagers we know how
they are with doors stopped
what
the door this door is broken
our door oh that room yeah there's like
10. there's four right at the store hey
guys i figured out a positive thing
about
being at such low health yeah
when i take fall damage i just heal
you sure
do where's the turret
have we not gotten back to where my nerd
is it's it's it's it's in you know it's
in my mind
right right right i don't know
right there a-hole
no oh
turn on our brighter light is that
better
[Laughter]
there are
uh six in the immediate vicinity two in
the wings
there another door up here or am i full
of there's no door up here
pull up my pistol and shoot and run why
would you do that because there's more
that i can count to just there's four of
us there's four on the right and there's
four on the left that makes five on the
okay so
bob you take right i'll take left with
uh sean here wade you fall bob in
and uh we'll get them all
one in the middle two in the middle two
on the right four on the left
all right all right wait you get that
one in the middle and then uh flank
right and we'll go left
on it oh you're so pretty
there's no way we're gonna be able to
move over there
let's try our best you oh god oh god
here
come on all right window
are you getting the one yeah that's so
much further away i'm getting this one
before i go further in all right you get
the one on the ground i'm gonna get the
one standing and then i'll run to the
other ones and you run and you walk over
with your spear
all right
all right we going yeah whenever you
guys are ready
three
two
charged
we can get him we're good
we got more over here sleeping
yeah everyone stop running why were you
running
okay you're good you're good you're good
you're good you're good we're good
so talented
you're good where when
were you when even was you upstairs
upstairs not me knowing this
upstairs uh tell me to charge
uh charge it up
charging three two one excuse me do you
need a melter
[Music]
please sir i'm just a lonely spearman i
happen to have some extra melters in my
back
i don't know why you're like nigel
thornberry with the melters but
sometimes it's kind of what it sounded
like sometimes the thornberry courses
through you
do you want a big lighty
i got big lighting no i got glow you
need to be the big lady with my big lady
oh what if i
touched him
you are captain [ __ ]
would you cross light beams
our powers combined we are captain
stelio girl all right we got
three just outside the store and then
many more but they're scattered i don't
think they're
now in okay there's one here
oh miss parky again
i'm missing
this
okay
got it uh there's four over here you're
really you're really
like knifing around dude my knife skills
unmatched really you're really horse
knifing around right now yeah unmatched
in that no one's as bad as me wait you
can get those guys whenever you want
these guys probably won't trigger
okay we oh god
calm down
whatever you're doing stop it
do you guys need light
yeah if you could shine the sun down
here for a minute i just can't really
see what's going on
thank you uh yeah one on the other side
of this door just the one uh hey oh he's
hanging look how dangly hanging he is
say it to him again all right it is as
you see i'm gonna get these two oh
there's a third on the left
yeah well i'll come over there
got these two
[Music]
oh
yeah when you cancel it is like a push
so you have to aim away from the target
yeah yeah yeah
i learned that today
oh you know what else i learned if you
have your gun out and you press c you'll
do a quick shove with your melee weapon
and it'll push people back that's
interesting oh wait no if i did that it
just draws my knife it it does a shove
as well
it shoves it doesn't stab but it should
there's one on the right somewhere i see
that's fine you guys don't hear me
nice got him nice perfect it's
pronounced knife
just like we glued it up nice one mark
thanks i'm gonna kill him with my knives
that's fine oh dippy yeah
that's higher than four in case anyone
forgot how numbers it's okay though
because this is a really small room
that's really hard to navigate once it's
shrouded with enemies don't open that
door up there
i know you're thinking about that door
yeah do not that goes back to the other
room
and
if i think it we can funnel them down
just to this door if we leave that one
okay should i put my turn on the other
side that doesn't shoot anything
uh
well you got a bad mouth of your turret
man it's a piece of ass i think they're
going to feel useful fast i mean like a
gross one they're gonna come from that
door or this door
i think those are the only two ways that
people can come from here i feel like
every time we make statements like that
it's definitely not true no i mean look
there's no other way to get in this
place so sure sure i know i totally
acknowledge and see that yeah
and then it's not gonna happen wait i
think i know why your dirt doesn't shoot
anything you see how it's aimed at like
the
the concrete
are you trying to kill the evergreen
over here i wanted to hit things as they
like we're trying to break in the door
because i think we're going to steal
that yeah you know what's that you know
what's a good angle for that
something like this
okay that'll shoot at the door and it'll
hurt the door oh well whatever that
doesn't really happen that's what we're
talking about
all right has a knife he knows what he's
talking about do you think anyone
playing this game for the first time
would use a knife
i'm going to come on this door watch out
oh god
wow
holy [ __ ] is it only like three little
goopy balls to fully do a door is it
more than that i think it's a full
charge i think you need it
maybe like a little less hey we're doing
the thing okay i guess now you always
act surprised what else are we going to
do
we were all screwing around i don't know
i don't know i don't know
i don't know
where are you going curvy
so i said my dick every morning
oh are they coming through that upper
door they're coming through that
wait you know what that's not a smart
thing to do with my turret for the
moment
batten down to
this is there's a hatches
next to you damn it there we go i
couldn't get that one circle down
help
no put me down don't go down i got you i
got you okay you you're under control
minus two that's what i'm at
uh it's called down whoa
oh don't do it not to me
why is it not working oh
oh i went down
that's fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine
this is fine we're fine
how's the weather mark oh good how are
you doing
okay hold down here
oh my shots are not connected
yeah i i think it was because my turrets
once again doing nothing they have a
thing where they go through the path of
least resistance so because the other
door wasn't seafoamed i think that's why
they went through that one oh mama i
think
is it bad time to say i'm down as well
uh i'm good yeah everyone was dead but
wow way to let us down
yep
so they have like preventative measures
against stacking the door uh yeah well
they just go again they go through like
the easiest path right
holy [ __ ] what is happening
i literally saw it there was a light in
the corner wait it was not mark's life
no no no i saw his light and my light
was not on i just watched him turn it on
as you were yelling at him his light was
a visual glitch because i saw his light
[Music]
i'm many things a liar is only part of
them
a liar is only most of them mark there
was a guy over here there's a guy over
there running around you're right oh for
[ __ ] sake why
wait why aren't you dead already
because they pissed something off and my
dude went all red and flashy on me
i did but i went i got it
god we're so weak in front of them
god watch one day wait i want to be a
cool spear guy you all right you're all
right guys we were cool last time with
spirits i'm just talking like this
it's more of a weight issue than it is a
spear issue i'm not upset this is how i
talk it's just a combination of things
we used to be doing great you know the
saying knife guys finish last
[ __ ]
i am helping
i also killed goods hey hey hey
your job man that was awesome
thank you
like you thank you thank you you're
welcome yeah you [ __ ] hear that
i have not [ __ ] up twice and still
been [ __ ] by your [ __ ] what yeah
you keep saying that dude it takes me
two hits with this knife to break a lock
you did it in one
that was dope as hell that's insane
that's so cool to be fair the amount of
time i would have taken you to swing
twice is how long it takes me to charge
no no no oh you weren't right oh right
that guy good job wait oh
no yeah good job good
oh oh
no no wait yeah no no not oh not oh he
like he like post trauma twitch i didn't
know if it was alive what's our strategy
this time
i'm gonna put a turn up at the door that
we thought they couldn't come in yeah
should i put one here again you got
enough come for both doors oh i can call
them anywhere you want baby
i was like i have to commit to the
sentence why would i even say it if i'm
not going to do it
yeah
call me come here
get him before he gets through the door
again wait no one's on the other side of
these doors are they
[Laughter]
i thought i didn't see bob's name
like oh god i can't stop i'm sorry
uh
we have fun we have fun yep they're
doing the high door bob's door yep it'll
hold it'll hold oh hey oh hey look this
is dangerous oh hey
they're about to gut up in there the
circle was all
all right here they go made the gum
okay that's that's plenty of that's
plenty that's enough
that's enough enough
you shall not can you ping them it's
really [ __ ] artistic oh yeah yeah you
got it oh god my face
i wish you hadn't done that i didn't
need to see that number
okay oh hey there's a big o i'm gonna
snipe the big o
good snipe he's dead
oh i almost just shot one of these gang
complete
please don't be more
we done we done our gorge
wow i'm gonna go all the way around and
grab my turro
that was effective yeah i think we did
good how did we mess that up so badly
last time because we only combed one so
we should have came twice
my life
classic
it can't be
no choice i can't think of what that's
the classic thing of but we all know it
i remember when my grandmother taught me
that lesson all right i hope we get some
health oh right this room oh hey
right properly
how many are there
there's
so many
so no achilles i wouldn't
i mean if you can
go
i mean how how many is so many because i
can kill three right now with one clip
there's ten in this room okay that's
that's more than i would have thought
wait we sneak i like sneaking oh i went
the wrong way
i mean don't go that way
that's my way to see where mark went
because he has the knife
i also have a scanner
[Music]
please do not trigger them because i
will [ __ ] you would be so dead wait duke
stop and look oh
there's another one
i hate it here
i hate everything
wade is like staring at his own feet
walking around
mark's ass mark stops and screams i stop
you know i stop and then wait and then i
scream after you move there's a certain
chain of events
he'll see it and after a second and a
half of absolute horror markets like no
i hear the thumpy heart beat and mark
scream i'm like hey time to stop so glad
i'm on my own over here uh yeah you
picked the right hey we all got here
we're fine
we got some
seafoam let's be careful yeah be careful
about that i guess it's not such a great
great
okay
oh hey look
okay it's fine because if we close this
door we can take out these guys and i
don't think the ones behind will we kill
one bob snipe mother yeah we just gotta
get in and close the door
okay okay it's just you can't nope it's
four there's there's one behind that
like uh folding thing wait we
i got a shotgun too that can take it out
in like a few shots
or the shotgun mark i have i have the
choke mode shotgun okay oh yeah that's
like a three shot which would be the
booklet
bob
uh that's two right in front of us would
be easy for me because i could see both
their heads yeah very cleanly
who's not too far out of the picture
either yeah i can't go for that if we
snap one then pull out shotguns kill the
other one and bob gets the two no
stabbing there's no chance i'm not
waiting there wait wait wait wait i'm
gonna shoot this one on the left in the
back of the head because like i said
that'll be more damage and my shotgun
should be able to two shot it if i do
that
okay so i'm gonna take out the two in
front of the blue door
and then uh you guys be ready to i'll
try and get all three down here where's
the fourth one it's behind the it's
behind the foldy all right well there's
no better time than now i guess uh i
will call my shot everyone ready yep yep
firing in three two
one bang bang
down this one's down
awesome there we go
we did not trip any of the ones outside
we're good
we're good bob did you snipe a third one
yeah i got him when he walked out
[ __ ]
i basically aimed at the same little
area it was not that hard
you're so handsome and talented
oh that spear guy could never
bob you did so good you get some health
you get some health i don't get some
health and that's it because that's the
choice
i don't deserve it i don't deserve it
oh now i'm a better person because of
you
don't be suspicious
put it on the door
wade i am going to give you one of these
ammunitions
wait nothing's in here oh wait this time
never mind
i'm going to give you the other one of
these ammunitions and i'm going to make
everyone have a heart attack
hey it worked
you're all right
so good i don't know if you guys
remember what's in this room is this the
sucky sucky boy room yeah oh yeah look
it is that's a five five oh that's too
many that's too many not for you
not for you
my gun has three bullets for mag there's
no way no okay strategy
no shooty remember shooty they all do
that's what kill us
yep i'm here remember this is sphere
moment to shine
great tentacle bigger than its fear
no you can get it if you one hit it with
the spear in the back of the head you
can kill it
or we try to sneak through or we try to
sneak through there is a zero percent
chance we're gonna be able to sneak
through this
i can get like one that guy on the left
is easy
okay i'm gonna try get this guy i'm i
apologize in advance i'll have i am
ready for you i am ready to back you up
my dude i'm ready to back up
hello okay
come on the door come on the door come
on this door
the doors don't close come on that door
the one behind us where all the bigs are
gonna come from god
oh we are back
so
my spear wasn't long enough she was
walking away
oh no oh god oh god the bigs behind us
are about to be such a problem guys
sure
oh my god
[Music]
you